16 jahre ist das jetzt her dass das
letzte mal ein überschallflugzeug
concorde passagiere superschnell und
luxuriös von a nach b gebracht hatte
flugzeit new york london
reinheim stunden irre jetzt werden pläne
für mögliche nachfolger der concorden
immer konkreter schon 2035 könnten
schätzungen zufolge weltweit und 2000
dieser superflieger geben klicks um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann und nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts herzlich willkommen benannt wurde
sie auch und donnervogel oder königin
der lüfte die concorde brauchte nur
dreieinhalb stunden von london nach new
york den todesstoß versetzte ihr das
unglück im juli 2000 bei dem tragischen
absturz nach dem start am pariser
flughafen kamen 113 menschen ums leben
alle passagiere sowie auch die besatzung
das bedeutete das ende des projektes wo
überhaupt das umstrittenste der
luftfahrtgeschichte
zwar gab es nochmal eine fluggenehmigung
aber dann 2003 wenn von anfang an war
die diskussion über die concorde groß es
ging um den lärm der triebwerke und so
wurde es dem überschalljet verboten die
maximale geschwindigkeit über land zu
fliegen
das war nur über dem ozean erlaubt ein
weiteres problem der so genannte
überschallknall ein verdammt lauter
knall der bei dem verdichtung ausstoß
entsteht wenn das flugzeug schneller
fliegt als der schall in seiner umgebung
die schallgeschwindigkeit ist dabei von
verschiedenen faktoren abhängig wie
beispielsweise der luftdichte und der
temperatur das verrückte dabei im
flugzeug selbst ist der knall nicht zu
hören weshalb dem passiert passagieren
der concorde immer in diesen
einzigartigen moment champagner
ausgeschenkt wurde in einer höhe von elf
kilometern liegt die
schallgeschwindigkeit beispielsweise bei
rund 1000 60 stundenkilometern doch
trotz der großen probleme sind sich
luftfahrt experten und expertinnen
sicher dass die überschallflugzeuges
schon bald ein comeback feiern werden
und so tüfteln nicht nur große firmen
wie beispielsweise lockheed martin oder
airbus an neuen überschall geräten für
internet continental reisen sondern auch
viele start ups umwelt und
verkehrsexperten und expertin vom
international council on clean
transportation dies haben jetzt eine
veröffentlicht nachdem bereits im jahr
2035 etwa 2000 überschallflugzeug
unterwegs sein werden und dass
tatsächlich an flughäfen weltweit wie
beispielsweise dubai london heathrow
frankfurt und new york rund 160
flughäfen werden in diesem szenario von
den überschallflugzeugen angesteuert
teilweise mit mehr als 100 starts und
landungen pro tag bei der entwicklung
vorne mit dabei ist beispielsweise
boeing der konzern hatte im sommer 2008
zehn das konzept für den sogenannten
hyper sonic at vorgestellt dieser soll
mit fünffacher schallgeschwindigkeit
fliegen in der fachsprache auch als
macht fünf bezeichnend hierbei ist die
macht zahl eine dimension slow zz angabe
der fluggeschwindigkeit konkret zeigt
sie das verhältnis der
fluggeschwindigkeit zur
schallgeschwindigkeit in der umgebung
diese fünffache schallgeschwindigkeit
des hyper sonic es wäre wahnsinn wie der
vergleich mit der concord zeigt die
schaffte damals maximal 2,2 tatsächlich
also eine art super flieger und so wird
die entwicklung sicherlich auch noch
einige jahre in anspruch nehmen bis zu
30 jahren werden wir wohl noch darauf
warten müssen so die angaben von boeing
selbst anders dagegen sehen die pläne
des us start ups bump technologies aus
schon 2020 also nächstes jahr soll die
overtüre in betrieb gehen wenn auch nur
mit macht 2,2 zu den investoren des
projekts gehören beispielsweise google
airbnb und dropbox die vision des
unternehmens passagiere für rund 2000
euro
in rund drei stunden von london nach new
york bringen bei der concorde kostet
sind dieser luxus damals übrigens
umgerechnet 16.000 euro auch das
unternehmen airbus ist beim thema
überschallflugzeug mit am start und
entwickelt derzeit den business jet as2
schon 2023 sollen ein erstflug
stattfinden
2025 könnten dann erst einmal bis zu
zwölf passieren passagiere abheben
später sollen dann deutlich mehr
passagiere transportiert werden können
doch es gibt auch staatliche bemühen
überschallflugzeugen wiederzubeleben
im frühling 2008 10 machte die us
weltraumbehörde nasa ernst und gab ein
überschallflugzeug in auftrag und zwar
wurde der rüstungskonzern lockheed
martin beauftragt einen prototypen des
sogenannten explain zu entwerfen zu
bauen und zu
etwa 200 millionen euro ist der nasa das
wäre der plan explain soll in 16.000
kilometern höhe fliegen und zwar mit
1500 kilometern pro stunde seine
spezielle bauform soll den lauten knall
verhindern und zwar indem die
schallwellen nicht miteinander
verschmelzen sondern in kleine stücke
zerteilt werden
die bezeichnung des designs quitt super
sonic technology damit können die jets
dann direkt nach dem start in den
überschall modus geben damit würde dann
sogar die reisezeit noch einmal verkürzt
werden eine miniatur version des neuen
nasa überschallflugzeuges wurde schon im
windkanal getestet im jahr 2022 soll
dann das endgültige passagierflugzeug
mehrere tests durchlaufen
für die bevölkerung auf der erde soll es
nach nasa-angaben dann im besten fall
nicht lauter sein als das zuschlagen
einer autotür oder ein donnergrollen
umwelt experten und expertinnen sind
dennoch pessimistisch sie warnen davor
dass viele länder darunter auch
deutschland mit regelmäßigen
überschallknall rechnen müssen
die region rund um die flughäfen seien
durch den extremen lärm bei start und
landung dann unbewohnbar naja aber dann
würde natürlich ein verbot greifen hinzu
kämen nach angaben der aktuellen oecd
studie 100 millionen tonnen zusätzliches
co2 und das ist wirklich ein problem das
würde ihnen die entlassungs ferien
gelangen pures gift für das weltklima
also und so fordert die
non-profit-organisation dass sich die
unternehmen und hersteller der
überschallflugzeuges schon jetzt auf
umweltstandards konzentrieren könnten
wir einen weltraum aufzubauen klickt auf
dieses video mega spannendes thema bei
doktor watson unbedingt anschauen und
abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran